nous sommes avec estelle youssoufa
présidente du collectif citoyen de
mayotte bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors on l'a vu le
défenseur des droits qui dénonce un
problème d'accès aux services publics
aux droits à mayotte
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui sur
l'île écoutez nous pour nous le rapport
du défenseur des droits ne fait qu
écrire noir sur blanc ce que les
mahoraises et les mahorais constate tous
les jours c'est un territoire français
nous sommes français depuis 1841
mais la réalité qui est constaté c'est
qu'en effet les mauvaises est mort et
n'ont pas accès à l'éducation à la santé
comme le reste des français et pour nous
c'est un combat de tous les jours je
pense que ce qui est important dans le
rapport c'est aussi de constater que le
défenseur des droits va dans le sens de
la défense du droit des étrangers ce qui
à mayotte pose un problème conséquent
parce que c'est un petit peu le serpent
qui se mord la queue si vous voulez le
défenseur des droits dit il faut plus de
droits pour les étrangers or c'est la
surabondance de demander de pression
migratoire qui fait qu'à mayotte l'état
n'assume pas ses responsabilités et ça
aussi c'est le défenseur des droits qui
le constate pour bien qu'on comprenne ça
veut dire que l'état finalement se
préoccupe beaucoup plus davantage du
problème de la migration de la lutte
contre l'immigration que la cible des
conditions de vie en fait des mahorais
aujourd'hui nous pour nous à mayotte ce
qu'ont constaté ce qu'on déplore c'est
le double langage de l'état par rapport
à mayotte c'est à dire que nos
frontières sont grandes ouvertes
on est régie s'est expliqué dans le
rapport on est régi par des règles
particulières des règles d'exception qui
font que l'état distribue des permis de
séjour qui cantonne les étrangers
c'est-à-dire les comoriens en très très
grande majorité ça fixe les comoriens à
mayotte mais à côté de ça le discours
officiel qui a été entendu par exemple à
l'assemblée nationale est de dire il ne
faut pas offrir trop de droits à mayotte
parce que ça aurait un effet d'appel
d'air comment est-ce que ça se traduit
pour les mahoraises et les mahorais qui
sont je le rappelle des ressortissants
francs
c'est ça veut dire qu'on a seulement 1,6
lit d'hôpital pour 1000 habitants alors
que ces six lits d'hôpital par habitant
pour la métropole
ça veut dire qu'il y a seulement 20
médecins généralistes pour une
population aussi celle de deux cent
cinquante six mille habitants
vingt médecins généralistes et 0
médecins scolaires pour cent mille
élèves à mayotte alors c'est ça non mais
je pense qu'il faut comprendre parce que
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour nous
mahoraise est mort et ça veut dire qu'on
va à l'hôpital et qu'on n'est pas soigné
ça veut dire que ma musique on les
catastrophes sérieuses ou face à une
problématique on retrouve dans de
nombreux départements d'outre-mer
l'accès au droit
les conditions de vie est ce que vous
vous diriez que le cas de mayotte un cas
atypique inédit en effet vous avez
raison la question de la détresse
ultramarines elle est réelle la
problématique pour mayotte c'est qu'on
est avec la guyane le territoire qui est
le plus touché par l'immigration
clandestine à mayotte plus de 52% de la
population est né hors du territoire
comptabilisés ça veut dire que sur la
proportion d'immigration clandestine on
connaît pas exactement les chiffres la
question pour mayotte c'est qu'on est en
train d'assister au départ à l'exode des
mahorais qu'on remplace la population
par des comoriens et des comédiennes qui
sont entrés illégalement sur le
territoire et qui utilise la loi pour
rester est ce qu'on voit avec le
défenseur des droits je vais terminer
parce que c'est très important le
défenseur des droits on se demande quel
droit il défend est ce qu'il défend
celui des morts s des mahorais qui sont
des français ou est-ce qu'il défonce
celui des étrangères et des étrangers et
qui participe ainsi implicitement un
discours qui met en avant le fait que
les étrangers n'ont pas accès à leurs
droits alors qu'ils sont entrés
illégalement sur le territoire mais que
par contre les mauvaises et les mahorais
doivent eux serrer les dents et
constater avec le défenseur des droits
l'incurie de l'état mais par contre il
n'y a aucun effort qui est fait pour la
défense alors que l'époux comment les
pouvoirs publics justement doivent
prendre cette question de l'immigration
à mayotte en guyane également nous pour
nous c'est très simple on est une île
donc à partir du moment où on protège de
lagon on l'a déjà dit à plusieurs
reprises il ya aucun bâtiment de la
marine nationale qui croise entre
anjouan et mayotte
on laisse nos frontières grande ouverte
il s'agit pas de faire du chiffre avec
des reconduites à la base ces personnes
ne doivent pas pouvoir rentrer le
président sarkozy l'avait fait il y
avait eu un bâtiment de la marine
nationale qui protéger nos frontières et
ça avait été efficace on peut pas avoir
des opérations chic en dry je sais pas
quelle autre opération officielle pour
faire les gros bras ou à voir le chef de
l'état qui vient sur votre île pour dire
on fait des limites de la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine
à la base il faut qu'il y ait un
discours clair des autorités françaises
pour réaffirmer que mayotte est
française depuis 1841 et que c'est le
choix des mauvaises et des mahorais de
rester au sein de la république et il
faut que paris soit ferme avec les
comores et se battre au niveau de la
scène internationale pour défendre nos
frontières
merci beaucoup estelle youssoufa je
rappelle que vous êtes président du
collectif citoyen de mayotte